le début d'année 2010 8 aura été arrosée
et froid dans les yvelines
fin janvier la crue de la seine inonde
le nord du département des pluies qui
laisse place en février à de nombreux
flocons bonsoir à tous mercredi 7
février bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
sur tv 78 édition spéciale ce soir
largement consacré à la neige et ses
répercussions dans le département des
intempéries qui ont paralysé le
territoire transports en commun à
l'arrêt certains automobilistes sont
même restés bloqués toute la nuit sur
les chaussées impraticables
un quotidien perturbé pour les yvelinois
qui ont dû faire preuve d'imagination
pour se déplacer un début d'année marqué
également par la visite de plusieurs
ministres dans notre département
agnès buzyn ministre des solidarités de
la santé venus à plaisir pour des
rencontres autour de la petite enfance
nous voyons qu'il va falloir intervenir
sur le repérage l'identification des
besoins sur l'accès aux droits sur la
formation des professionnels attrape le
tout nouvel institut ellen nanotech
destinés à mesurer l'infiniment petit
est inaugurée en présence de la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie telle fille jenny stefan un
déplacement tourner vers les sciences
également pour jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
était en visite au lycée emilie de
breteuil à montigny le bretonneux
un établissement qui propose plusieurs
formations scientifiques
un souhait du gouvernement enfin la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
s'est rendu à méré en ce début d'année
dans un espace dédié au coworking
c'est une bonne manière de permettre ce
que ce à quoi aspire 61 % de nos
concitoyens
le travail il en était aussi question le
jeudi 29 mars
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a accueilli la
première édition en piste pour l'emploi
au programme rencontres avec des
employeurs échanges avec les entreprises
du territoire
en tout quatre mille offres d'emploi ont
été proposés aux saint quentinois
des saint quentinois qui ont pu
emprunter dès le mois de mars la toute
nouvelle route départementale 30 à
plaisir après trois ans de travaux la
deux fois deux voies est enfin ouverte
c'est la base même d'une femme qui est
les fondamentaux pour que notre ville
puisse avoir des aspirations encore
supplémentaires dans un développement à
la fois commercial économique et un
cadre de vie pour emprunter la ligne 18
il faudra en revanche encore attendre la
nouvelle tombe en février la livraison
du premier tronçon est retardé arrivé au
plus tard en 2027 sur le plateau de
saclay et non plus en 2024
[Musique]
sur le plan culturel en janvier le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
a fêté ses 30 ans depuis trois décennies
l'établissement versailles et oeuvre à
la valorisation du patrimoine musical
des xviie et xviiie siècles lui a laissé
le temps d'une soirée la musique pour
déclamer les grands discours qui ont
fait l'histoire de l'assemblée nationale
début 2018 joey starr était à l'affiché
du théâtre montansier à versailles pour
éloquence à l'assemblée ôtez leur peine
de mort pour moi la force et forcé
encore des bouts de taux si l'union et
la misère enfin le premier trimestre
2010 8 a également été sportif avec du
cyclisme et le départ le 4 mars dans les
yvelines de la 76e édition du paris-nice
déception samedi 6 janvier pour l'équipe
de rouille le club de foot yvelinois
chute en 32e de finale de la coupe de
france de football battu 3 buts à 0 par
concarneau
près de 2000 supporters étaient venus
encourager le petit poucet de la
compétition
un match sans enjeu en revanche le
samedi 24 mars dans l'enceinte du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'anciennes gloires du psg se sont
affrontés pour la bonne cause
le 15e trophée du gol de letra trophée
créé par rail afin de récolter des dons
en faveur des enfants défavorisés
brésilien